sie drücken sich meistens ziemlich
erfolgreich die tech giganten die in der
pandemie noch reicher wurden olaf scholz
will sie zur kasse bitten weltweit zum
ersten mal
[Musik]
große geschichte im moment ist andere
sehen hier die worte größer als die
ergebnisse
herr scholz hat versucht ein so
ambitionslose kompromiss zu finden das
auch facebook beifall geklatscht hat es
gibt viele die sich drücken wege suchen
und finden steuern zu vermeiden skrupel
fehlanzeige
moral ist sogar gerechtfertigt oder
sogar das einzige richtige eben keine
steuern zu zeigen und die normalos
zahlen sie am ende die zeche einfach
weil es schon immer so war
ja ist so und wir müssen zahlen
[Musik]
es gibt fluchtpunkte an die es auf jetzt
menschen zieht um wahlkampf pandemie und
politik zu vergessen
mallorca in der zweiten corona saison
abschalten vom virus zu hause und der
debatte um die rettungsmilliarden wer
soll das eigentlich bezahlen
letztendlich stelle ich mir die frage
nicht weil letztendlich bleibt diese so
am steuerzahler wie da dranhängen die
pandemie die betrifft uns alle jeden
einzelnen und ist auch irgendwo von
jedem einzelnen einsatz zu erwarten
möchte würde ich doch sagen wie sie
wirklich sind wie viele millionen im
jahr wollen wir mal millionen 2 abgeben
zu denen weniger baby von unserer einen
in fünf oder zehn euro schein er will
das nicht christoph scheuermann reist
nicht zur entspannung sondern um steuern
zu sparen seit sechs jahren ist der
deutsche ohne festen wohnsitz unterwegs
das ziel kein staat soll an seinen
gewinnen mitverdienen wie das geht da
hat er sich von den ganz großen
inspirieren lassen von amazon google und
co
[Musik]
das heißt verschiedene lebens aspekte in
verschiedene länder zu verlagern zum
beispiel eben seinen wohnsitz im land
seine firma einen anderen land und sein
konto wiederum ineinander land ja so wie
bei mir ist es so ich habe mein
hauptwohnsitz unter anderem in dubai
meine firma ist aber in den usa mein
konto wiederum ist in europa weil meine
kunden vor allem in deutschland
österreich und der schweiz sitzen das
heißt sie ermöglichen es kunden normalen
menschen zu agieren wie google facebook
usw genau das ist der plan und damit
verdient heuermann laut eigener aussage
bis zu 100.000 euro monatlich mit
vorträgen büchern und beratung wie man
sein geld am fiskus vorbei bringt gerade
in der pandemie wo der deutsche staat
milliarden für die rettung von
unternehmen aus gibt wächst das
interesse am prinzip heuermann
sehr viele mittel stehen sehr viele
leute die in deutschland stark verankert
sind aber mittlerweile keine große lust
mehr das ganze die nächsten jahre zu
finanzieren und suchen sowohl privat als
auch teilweise für unternehmen lösungen
beuermann will seine idee und das volk
bringen und so der solidargemeinschaft
zeigen was eine harke ist
für mich sind das für mich ist das moral
ist sogar gerechtfertigt oder sogar das
einzige richtige eben keine steuern zu
zahlen
solche ideen hat gerrit zachrich in
bamberg nicht mit seinem programm kino
hatte die lok downs nur mit hilfe von
spenden und staatshilfe überlebt große
rücklagen fehlanzeige zach ich bezahlt
etwa 30 prozent steuern in deutschland
während andere wege finden sich darum zu
drücken
mir ist es klare sich abgaben zahlen und
ich finde es müsste ich eben anderen
eigentlich auch klar sein gerade wenn
man so auf dem prüfstand ist mit
koronarer reist das weiße harte zeit für
alle weil es gibt auch noch leute denen
sie schlechter geht als mir und die doch
viel schwerer über die runden gekommen
sind und wie soll wie sieht es für die
aus wenn wenn es leute gibt die daran
verdient haben während der pandemie bad
sachlich in seinem kino oft alleine
gewinner haben mit dem
unterhaltungsbedürfnis der menschen
andere eingefahren denn statt dem kino
schauten die deutschen im lockdown zu
hause filme auf netflix
[Musik]
mehr als elf millionen abonnements hat
der streaming dienst in deutschland
verkauft umsatz eine milliarde euro im
jahr
die fließt aber nicht nach berlin wo die
deutschland tochter des konzerns sitzt
die millionen gehen am deutschen fiskus
vorbei
zunächst in die niederlande hier
betreibt netflix sein europa geschäft
und sammelt die umsätze nahezu
steuerfrei ein und weiter geht's in
richtung usa
hier laufen alle einnahmen von netflix
zusammen die 140 millionen euro
jahresgewinn aus deutschland erreichen
die konzernzentrale in kalifornien
deutschland ging auf dieser reise
praktisch leer aus denken sie daran wie
die kinos zum beispiel gelitten haben
unter der krone krise die festival
betreiber die kulturszene und dann kommt
netflix für die das natürlich goldene
zeiten machen weil die leute zu hause
auf der couch saßen und dann dort filme
geguckt haben und zahlt steuern wo sich
jeder handwerker seien dreimal umdrehen
würde und sagen würde also ich hab eine
viel höhere steuerrechnungen hier zu
begleichen das ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehbar
deshalb wollen in der lagunenstadt
venedig die
g20-finanzminister im juli das
steuerdumping beenden auf initiative des
deutschen olaf scholz der plan ein
unternehmen wie netflix soll seine
abgaben in zukunft vermehrt dort zahlen
wo das geld verdient wird
zum beispiel in deutschland
außerdem soll jedes unternehmen weltweit
eine mindeststeuer von 15 prozent
bezahlen das heißt ein fiktiver konzern
der irgendwo auf der welt 5 prozent
steuern auf seine gewinne bezahlt muss
die differenz zu 15 prozent am hauptsitz
des unternehmens abführen so sollen
steueroasen trockengelegt werden
in diesem moment glaube ich schon dass
das ein großer geschichte im moment ist
in dem er alle drei sind ein moment bei
dem eine hundertjährige praxis
internationalen besteuerung von
unternehmen geändert wird die g 20
staaten haben sich jetzt hier darauf
verständigt dass sie ein neues eine neue
ordnung der internationalen besteuerung
miteinander vereinbaren wollen
an der westküste der usa sitzen die
wertvollsten konzerne der welt
google zahlte in deutschland im letzten
jahr gerade mal 3,7 prozent steuern
apple kam auf rund 3 prozent
netflix sogar nur auf 0,2
das zdf magazin frontal hat renommierte
steuerexperten beauftragt zu berechnen
was die reform für deutschland verändert
christoph trautvetter steht in engem
kontakt mit den experten von regierung
und g20 so kann er für uns berechnen was
die pläne deutschland einbringen am
beispiel von zwei konzernen ergibt sich
folgendes ergebnis
google zahlt demnach statt bisher 3,6 in
zukunft 7,3 prozent steuern in
deutschland
netflix stadt 0,2 prozent 0,3
das globale steuersystem ist insgesamt
abgesehen von dem sieg gegen die
steueroasen nicht gerechter und auch
nicht einfacher geworden und ist nach
wie vor so kompliziert dass große
digital konzerne große konzerne
insgesamt ihre steuern nicht bezahlen wo
sie tatsächlich sie auch erwirtschaften
die einigung der g 20 bringt deutschland
also de facto keine steuergerechtigkeit
doch im wahlkampf erzählt
kanzlerkandidat scholz seine geschichte
vom großen sieg der politik gegen das
ganz große geld
ich guck mal wo man ganz wenig steuern
zahlt und da zahle ich sie und sagt den
anderen ihr könnt jetzt ja nix mehr
verlangen das haben große konzerne
gemacht und deshalb haben amazon google
facebook und all die anderen auch am
allerwenigsten steuern gezahlt weil das
mit ihrem geschäftsmodell besonders
einfaches
nachfrage wie kann es sein dass netflix
auch in zukunft in deutschland kaum
steuern zahlt
sie haben sich glaube ich überwiegend
verrechnet
verrechnet wir zeigen scholz antwort dem
steuerexperten trautvetter in diesem
fall haben wir tatsächlich nach der
besten datenlage berechnet und nichts
vergessen also dieser vorwurf ist
tatsächlich einfach falsch nächster
versuch den kanzlerkandidaten mit
unseren berechnungen zu konfrontieren
mit der globalen mindestbesteuerung die
wir als reformen im blick haben und die
sie bei ihren berechnungen nicht
übersehen dürfen aber fürchte ich ein
wenig übersehen haben ist es so dass wir
sicherstellen dass wir die steuern die
dort nicht erhoben werden als differenz
zusätzlich nehmen können die
mindeststeuer haben wir natürlich
eingerechnet die hat allerdings zwei
haken sie sorgt nicht dafür dass die
digital konzerne auf ihre in deutschland
erwirtschafteten gewinne tatsächlich
nach deutschem recht in deutschland
steuern zahlen sondern diese
mindeststeuer wird in dem hauptsitz land
der konzerne fällig also vor allen
dingen in den usa
während die großen also weiterhin ihre
gewinne und verluste weltweit
schönrechnen und verschieben können muss
kinobetreiber zachrich dem finanzamt
bamberg 30 prozent seiner gewinne ab
treten und er muss sich wundern dass
ein jedes kino eigentlich auch unseren
staat bis in die kleinste steuerabgabe
unterstützt aber der streamingdienst
multinationaler konzern ist der häufig
noch nicht mal ein paar euro an abgaben
bezahlt im land also gerade steuer mäßig
hat mir alles gelesen diese
ungerechtigkeit bleibt und dieser sich
für einen kinobetreiber der jeden tag
sein kino aufschließt unikat
ungerechtigkeiten die in der pandemie
noch zugenommen haben
400 milliarden euro kostet es den
deutschen steuerzahler dass die
wirtschaft gestützt und unternehmen
gerettet wurden wo aber soll das geld
herkommen
der kampf gegen steuervermeidung bringt
in milliarden gerechnet relativ wenig
das trifft auf die vermögenssteuer nicht
zu die vermögenssteuer kann hohe erträge
bringen man da reden wir über ihr nach
ausgestaltung 10 bis 30 milliarden euro
zusätzliche einnahmen das würde reichen
um den crooner schulden zu bedienen und
die vermögenssteuer würde sie zur kasse
bitten die superreichen
die geschichte der vermögenssteuer
schlappe 130 jahre alt die diskussion
darum fast genauso alt
eingeführt wurde sie von kaiser wilhelm
dem zweiten im jahr 1893 findet sie sich
im preussischen ergänzungs steuergesetz
1952 beschließt der bundestag mit
kanzler adenauer die vermögenssteuer in
ihrer jetzigen form ausgerechnet die csu
verdoppelt sie 1995 mit ihrem
finanzminister theo waigel von 0,5 auf
ein prozent
im selben jahr wird sie vom
bundesverfassungsgericht gekippt als
ungerecht und in der folge ausgesetzt
aber niemals gänzlich abgeschafft und
alle vier jahre ist sie wieder in der
diskussion wenn wahlkampf ist in
deutschland
[Musik]
wenn man sich in anderen ländern
umschaut der schweiz in großbritannien
wird mit dem finanzminister gesprochen
konservative finanzminister in den usa
überall gibt es höhere
vermögensbesteuerung als in deutschland
und deshalb kann es auch nicht falsch
sein wenn wir das wieder einführen was
wir schon mal das ging dann auf seine
kosten klaus barbie ist im taunus mit
immobilien reich geworden sehr reich 1
prozent vermögenssteuer bin urlaub
scholz zum beispiel von ihm doch basti
findet dass nicht alle reichen gleich
sind
es gibt zwei kunden vom reiche die 1
gehabt haben die nichts getan haben und
es gibt die anderen die das wirklich
selbst geschafft haben und wenn leute
das selbst geschafft haben dass es die
gruppe die sollte man nicht belasten was
sie denkt dass ihm der reichtum zusteht
wie die gemeinschaft aber die milliarden
für die pandemie hilfen stemmen soll auf
alle fälle ohne das geld von busk ii
wissen sie ich hätte x-mal bankrott
gehen können weil ich bis auf den
letzten pfennig gepokert habe verstehen
sie und da habe ich keine lust wie das
von irgendwelchen leuten ich habe frau
ich habe kinder und
meine familie habe ich ernährt da meine
eltern meine mutter jahrelang
unterstützt und so weiter alle die damit
zusammenhängen dass wir davon
profitieren
doch die baskets haben in der politik
auch unterstützer einer ist ausgerechnet
olaf scholz potenzieller
koalitionspartner was die sache mit der
vermögenssteuer zumindest schwierig
machen könnte nach einer solchen
wirtschaftskrise wollen sie allen
ernstes einen aufschwung mit
steuererhöhungen
organisieren ich sage ihnen das glatte
gegenteil wäre richtig auf eine
wirtschaftskrise antwortet man mit
entlastungen wenn wir 400 milliarden
euro neue schulden gemacht haben werden
am ende des nächsten jahres um die krise
zu bekämpfen
dann ist das nicht der zeitpunkt wo
leute die so viel verdienen wie ich oder
noch mehr verdienen wie jemand wie ich
wo solche leute jetzt dringend eine
steuersenkung brauche
olaf scholz trifft im wahlkampf mit
seinen ideen einen nerv doch die globale
mindeststeuer bringt deutschland
ziemlich wenig und die vermögenssteuer
wären nur mit rot rot grün zu machen und
das wollen laut umfragen die wenigsten
[Musik]